ممثله مفبضيه الامم المتحده للاجئين قالت
انه تم تسجيل عبوري 4000 شخص من السودان
الى تشاد المجاوره والارقام الحقيقيه اكبر
من ذلك من بلده ادري على الحدود الجديده
السودانيه ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره فضل
عبد الرزاق فضل اذا
تشاد دوله مجاوره قريبه جدا لها علاقه
خاصه بالسودان من حيث
التداخل القبلي الموجود خاصه مع غرب
السودان
كيف هي الحركه في الحدود بين البلدين
انا ام عثمان التداخل القبلي بين الشات
والمنطقه الغربيه للسودان دارفور هو
اكبر من اي تداخل القبلي في الحدود
التجاريه مع البلدان الاخرى ولذلك
فالتاثيرات هي متبادله بين الجانبين وهذه
المره هو تسجيل
اللاجئين جدد من منطقه ولايه غرب دارفور
بالسودان الى منطقه
في تشاد الاف اللاجئين وصلوا الى الاراضي
الجاديه في هذه المنطقه كموجه جديده من
اللاجئين الذين يصلون اتباعا الى تشاد
ولكن المنظمات الانسانيه خاصه برنامج
الغذائي العالمي وكذلك المفوضيه الساميه
للاجئين التابعه للامم المتحده بالاضافه
الى المؤسسات الانسانيه التشاديه الان هم
في حاله تحرك من اجل احصاء عدد اللاجئين
الذين وصلوا الى هذه المنطقه وتزويدهم بما
يحتاجون اليه لكنهم يتحدثون عن ان
الامكانيات حتى الان هي امكانيات شحنها
ومتوفره لدى هذه المنظمات ولا تكفي سوى من
اجل الطوارئ ولذلك المناشدات تكثر على انه
ينبغي ان يتم تمويل
المؤسسات التي ستواجه
تسكين وايواء هؤلاء اللاجئين القلق في
المنطقه الحدوديه بين تشاد والسودان خاصه
في منطقه ادري هنا
شديد والحكومه الشاديه بسبب هذا القلق من
الناحيه الامنيه هي سياره الدوريات وزادت
عدد قوات الجيش في هذه المنطقه واتخذت
اجراء اساسي في هذه الايام هو اغلاق
الحدود رسميا ولذلك تشاهد خلفي هنا هذه
الشاحنات هي في الاساس الشاحنات سودانيه
نقلت بضائع الى تشاد ولكن بسبب اغلاق
الحدود هي الان متعطله في هذا المكان
بالاضافه الى شاحنات شاديه كان يفترض ان
تنقل هذه البضائع ايضا الى السودان وهي
تواجه نفس الوضع وهذا يتسبب في تاثير
اقتصادي بالغ في هذه المنطقه بالاضافه الى
التاثيرات الامنيه التي يعاني منها السكان
والاخبار التي تتحدث عن ان المعارك التي
تحدث في مدينه الجنينه التي تبعد سوى 30
كيلومتر من هذه المنطقه حدثت امس بين
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
والاشتباكات القبليه استمرت اليوم ايضا في
هذه المدينه الواق عه بالقرب من الحدود
التاليه السودانيه